[Music]
it's time for et social study your quick
look at what the stars are posting
online they're changing the world where
the next generation coming up Selena
Gomez is all about giving back the
singer shared this photo on Instagram
surprising some unsuspecting fans at a
high school in LA I really look forward
to it I'm so excited Kate Hudson is
feeling the love she posted this cute
throwback of her mom Goldie Hawn and dad
Kurt Russell's hey yo what's up Chris
Pratt here so I'm a little embarrassed
from my last video it seemed a little
weak Chris Pratt has been making us
laugh with his what's my snack video
series on Instagram but on Thursday he
hilariously clapped back at haters
accusing him of being too thin by
posting this photo he joked in the
caption I'm posting a current selfie of
me at would I consider a very healthy
weight
Nick Cannon showed off his sweat sesh at
the gym the TV host is totally ripped
seems like we're in for yet another
dramatic episode of Keeping Up with the
Kardashians on Sunday he posted new
promo clips on YouTube of Kendall and
Kylie handling scary situations I had
someone break into my house I'm like
crying I'm like freaking out so Kylie
tell us what's going on
[Music]
you